your good friend Dwayne Wade's going
into the Hall of Fame in a couple months
have you allowed yourself to think what
it would ever mean to you
to be elected into the Basketball Hall
of Fame yes I have and what do you think
don't care
you don't care whether you're a Hall of
Famer no I don't do you think your
resume
still don't care honestly speaking could
care less if we're being brutally honest
uh if I was elected to the Hall of Fame
I'm not going
you're not going to accept it no no I'm
not going like it's like the festivities
and all of that
I just want to like I just want to like
go put my feet in the sand somewhere
you wouldn't accept that honor the
greatest honor in basketball uh it's an
individual thing you know I'm not for
the individual type stuff I'm really not
I'm like a team guy
but even after it's all said and done
and you've no I don't want to go I don't
I'm not worried about the Hall of Fame
so I promise you it's an honor it is but
hmm I could care less
interesting I mean that too by the way